we have to start today with the supposed
bombshell from Rachel Maddow's an MSNBC
show last night in which she teased that
she had Donald Trump's tax returns now
the background on Donald Trump's tax
returns of course seventy-four percent
of Americans in a recent poll want to
see them endless reasons to see the tax
return some major some minor minor is
Trump as charitable as he claims to be
major is Trump beholden to foreign
interests and if so which ones and does
he owe money to foreign agents I like
Rachel Maddow this is not a criticism of
Rachel Maddow but rather of the total
set of decisions many of these not
directly related to Rachel Maddow let's
start with earlier in the day in the
evening Rachel Maddow teasing on Twitter
that they have the Trump tax returns
breaking we've got Trump tax returns
tonight 9pm Eastern MSNBC seriously so
Pat texted me a picture of this pat was
clearly excited I was excited at this
point we said wow this could be
something I mean I certainly was excited
at first glance but then you take a look
at that sweet and she's saying Trump tax
returns and I thought it was suspicious
that she was saying Trump and not
Trump's cuz that kind of opens it up to
anything well there was a second tweet
sent a sort of clarifying tweet from
Rachel Maddow which said what we've got
is from 2005 the president 1040 form
details to come tonight 9pm Eastern
MSNBC now at this point I knew this was
going to be a dud in fact here is a
picture of my text from Pat to Pat
rather in his response I said 20 minutes
before this went to air only the 1040 so
I don't think that includes charitable
donations and no business stuff since
that goes on schedule see unless they
have it all and indeed it could be on
schedule see it could be on a k1 form
there's a number of different places
where you would see specific business
information for someone's personal tax
return and again Pat correctly correctly
pointing out and it texts back to me
that the 95 return showed that Trump was
a billion in debt and was a void to pay
of able to avoid paying taxes
years because of it I don't know if it
was a billion in debt or a nearly
billion dollar loss but yes so at that
point that's what we knew then what
happens well we get to the Rachel Maddow
Show for about 20 minutes she does
background sort of an opener what why
would we want to see the tax returns etc
etc and it really ended up being pomp
and circumstance with very little
substance and Rachel Maddow brought on
David Cay Johnston the Pulitzer
prize-winning financial reporter to
analyze the returns and the source of
the returns was that these just ended up
in David K Johnston's mailbox so what
did we learn from these returns well we
learned that Donald Trump paid 38
million dollars in taxes in 2005 on
income of just over a hundred and fifty
million dollars that's about a
twenty-five percent effective tax rate
putting Donald Trump's tax rate in 2005
above a recent Obama effective tax rate
of nineteen percent this bombshell was
good for Donald Trump and some people
are focusing on well he wrote off a
hundred million dollars in losses that's
not news we know that he does that as
Pat mentioned the 1995 leaked return
showed that Trump writes off big losses
that's not news at all it was much ado
about nothing and here's where I come
out on this pad David Cay Johnston
actually proposed what I believe to be
the most likely scenario here this was
twenty seconds into the interview with
Rachel Maddow and it is the most
relevant part of the entire one-hour
episode here's David Cay Johnston da
came in the mail all over the transom
and there is absolutely nothing improper
about journalists if you haven't
solicited something getting it over the
transom and by the way let me point out
it's entirely possible the dot and sent
this to me Donald Trump has over the
years leaked all sorts of things the
very sleazy girl-on-girl pictures of the
first lady in the New York Post they
have come from Donald the front pages of
the state tax returns that we had
that were sent to the new york times in
the New York Daily News last fall may
have come from Donald on his long
history of leaking material about
himself when he thinks it's in his
interest that's exactly right Rachel
Maddow herself cited the White House as
the confirming source that these are
really Donald Trump's 20 2005-10 40
pages why do we have just the 2005 and
not another year well we don't know who
it came from but what we know is that
the 2005 1040 not having any other
schedules or forms is a favorable year
to be leaked for Donald Trump isn't it
well especially because that's when the
apprentice really took off i think that
was when he had his second season and of
course he's taking a big salary from NBC
in that year but also it's just a big
promotion for his businesses people
watch the show and then they want to
stay at Trump hotels and use his
products no doubt about it Trump
responding on Twitter to this about this
report clearly the entire Trump
lighthouse was watching this and Donald
Trump tweeting out after the report that
quote does anybody really believe that a
reporter who nobody ever heard of went
to his mailbox and found my tax returns
NBC News fake news okay that that's just
a bed that's just a show that Donald
Trump is putting on the only actual
interesting thing that we learned from
the tax returns is that a lot of the tax
that Donald Trump did pay was due to the
alternative minimum tax attacks which
Trump said he wants to get rid of but
did we really need to see Trump's
returns with all the pomp and
circumstance to learn that trumps tax
policy ideas would help really rich
people pay less in taxes no and there is
all sorts of reasons to speculate why
Trump might have weakness himself timing
to distract from the health care
disaster that is going on with the
Republican health care proposal I don't
know who got played here Pat but
somebody got played it could have been
David Cay Johnston it could have been
Rachel Maddow it could have been all of
us viewers who were texting back and
forth and anxiously awaiting the
releases that we that would happen at
nine p.m. Eastern last night I don't
know but someone got played and if this
has any impact at all on the
reception of Trump this helps Trump
because on this particular year all we
know is Trump paid a higher effective
tax rate than President Obama had paid
in some years I mean it seems like
Rachel Maddow and company were using
these 2005 returns to play to this
broader narrative of the reasons as to
why we need to see more of them and
maybe more are to follow but we already
kind of knew that there would be some
incriminating things in here potentially
yes seventy-four percent of Americans
already want to see the Trump tax return
so as a pretext for just saying hey the
tax returns matter and are important it
seems sort of like a waste of time to me
and most most of the people on my
Twitter feed Facebook stream seem to
generally agree with my point of view
let me know what you think